[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir meinen ohren
platz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber die zwölf der scheiß hier man ja
ich bin stinksauer ich will mit meinem
wagen hier durchfährt man porsche ja und
jetzt auf einmal alles gesperrt was
silos friedrichstraße die straße in
berlin eigentlich ja wir haben die
straße umgestaltet für die menschen hier
nicht mehr für die autofahrer jetzt
dürfen vorstellen branche waren sind
auch menschen ja ja aber relativ wenige
und wir müssen jetzt an alle menschen
denkt doch mal was was soll das empire
for sports was ist das hier von den
fahrzeugen ja wir sind fünf usern ja
dann sowas hab so leicht der reifen
reißen männer nicht so richtig bekannt
ja unterstützt weil sie zwar future die
jungen leute da bin ich schon aus daher
kommt auch nicht mehr hinter ihr habt
mir alle zu 115 us in berlin
aber für den fuchs wird jetzt der muss
ja und dafür nicht aus hier sind viele
menschen die stets jetzt menschen mit
zukunft auf diesem planeten hat
ja gut aber das war ja die straße
blockieren der autofahrer wie gesagt es
ist niemand die melkkühe der nation
steuern ohne ende aber eigentlich so
schwer aber ich kann verstehen wenn man
immer das größte stütze bekommen hat und
auf einmal teilen soll dann ist das
schwierig auch für den porsche fahrer
aber das werden sie ein bisschen dann
müssen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
luisa wirklichen nehmt mir alles was ich
noch habe mir habe ich nicht mehr im
leben als mein porsche man immer darüber
reden
ich bitte dich geständig hab ein
bisschen verständnis für uns ist wir
haben ihr seid auch am demonstrieren
habt ihr nicht manchmal den eindruck
dass man euch jungen leuten zu wirklich
zuhört muss ich habe ich denn die aktie
na gut ich meine ich werde es auf meinem
grab wenig interessiert weiter
beobachten die sie das versuchen dann
irgendwie genannt zu bekommen
die nachfolge-generation werden dich
lieben das höher werden dann denkmal
bauen aber lange schmutzig was hast du
gesagt ja sowas passiert öfter mal dass
ich heute so schön hoffentlich regnet
sollte nicht der loser für heute habe
ich genug von dieser sogenannten zukunft
damit zurück zurück in die vergangenheit
[Musik]
was denn die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]